der bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat der
ukraine die lieferung eines modernen
flugabwehr systems zugesagt außerdem
werde den ukrainischen streitkräfte nein
ortungs radar zur verfügung gestellt das
atelier aufklären können das sagte
scholz eben im bundestag bei der großen
generaldebatte ja was ist da dran das
müssen wir schon noch mal diskutieren
mit unserem chefreporter peter tiede
hatte ich das wirklich überrascht jetzt
du kannst du musst ja nachrichten
produzieren also da keine panzer schickt
und von allen seiten attackiert wird
weil er der ukraine nicht in
angemessenem umfang waffentechnisch
helfen würde dann produziert erhalten
die nachricht und das ist natürlich eine
tolle schau das ist gut gesetzt das ist
aus regierungshandeln du musst eine rede
halten und du weißt vorher du wirst
attackiert weil du keine kampfpanzer
schicksal bestimmte sachen einfach von
den listen streichen und weil das
gesamte westliche ausland inzwischen
zweifel an unseren bündnistreue oder an
unserer position hat dann sagst du halt
das tut ein flugabwehrsystem und ein
paar andere sachen liefert das ist neu
das ist gut aber es ist auch kein panzer
so setzt man nachrichten so macht man
das ansonsten war es ja auch ein sehr
spannender schlagabtausch erst die rede
von friedrich merz der richtig gas
gegeben hat auch richtig gegen olaf
scholz geschossen hat olaf scholz kam
dann und er konnte auch ganz gut dass
schauen uns noch mal
was verschweigen sie uns eigentlich herr
bundeskanzler
sie telefonieren 80 minuten mit dem
markt mit dem russischen
staatspräsidenten
und morgen kommt der parlament der
ukraine nach deutschland nach berlin und
sie verweigern bis zu dieser minute
einen gesprächstermin
warum ist kann's doch was ist da
eigentlich los in ihrer regierung putin
darf seine ziele nicht erreichen er darf
nicht mit seinem konzept durchkommen mit
einem brutalen militärischen einsatz ein
land zu erobern oder teile davon das ist
im realismus und den werden wir in
europa nicht akzeptieren über die
haltung der bundesregierung gibt es
mittlerweile nur noch verstimmungen
vorsichtig formuliert es gibt
enttäuschungen über die unklare rolle
deutschlands und es gibt richtig
verärgerung über sie und ihre regierung
und nicht nur während die opposition
abschließendes zitat für deutschland
bleibt jetzt nur noch verachtung übrig
es ist überheblich und es ist
unangemessen und es ist völlig fehl am
platze wenn hier zu lange darüber
diskutiert wird was die ukraine
richtigerweise zu entscheiden hat ich
sage es mit dem amerikanischen
präsidenten über die ukraine entscheiden
die ukraine ukraine und niemand braucht
putin darf und wird diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen
ich habe peter da muss man sagen genau
diesen satz hat er sehr häufig
wiederholt man hätte sich gewünscht dass
er einen anderen satz sagt ja die
ukraine darf muss den krieg gewinnen das
ist ersatz und den sich der kanzler
herumdrückt und da kann man auch noch
mal so oft machen wie man will das heißt
der kanzler macht ist ein rhetorischer
trick er sagt nichts neues macht aber
draußen regnet es und wir werden es
nicht hinnehmen dass wir das wären
deswegen spannen wir jetzt unseren sturm
auf das ist ein trick er sagt nichts
außer dass ein regenschirm dabei hat und
es ist inhaltlich führt das nicht weiter
aber es funktioniert das hat die
rhetorik von olaf scholz man muss aber
um das abzubinden ganz klar sagen es
waren zwei wirklich gute reden der
oppositionsführer hat das gemacht was
man als oppositionsführer zu beginn
einer debatte macht man fängt wenn man
jetzt so ein langes dickes seil
vorstellt man fängt langsam an das seil
zu schlagen immer höhere wellen die
amplitude wird wird immer höher und nach
hinten raus wenn man an den kanzler
übergibt macht man eine richtige welle
dann schiebt man riecht nicht an so dass
der kanzler drauf springen muss märz hat
das gemacht mit drei forderungen unter
anderem sagen sie uns klipp und klar
welche waffen wollen sie liefern sagen
sie uns klipp und klar was ist mit dem
beitrittskandidaten start ist für die
europäische union finden für die ukraine
und machen sie eine rentenreform und
damit hat er übergeben scholz hat das
level angenommen hat dass dann die wogen
dann gilt dann geglättet ist dann zu
seinem thema rübergegangen und stand
hinten raus als ich bin euer steuermann
wohin steuert hat er nicht wirklich
gesagt aber so macht man das und das ist
jetzt für die ältere generation mich zum
beispiel ich erinnere mich noch an den
deutschen bundestag in bonn ja bonn war
früher mal die bundeshauptstadt für die
jugend und zuschauer ja einige wenige
erinnern sich daran noch und ich kann
nicht daran noch erinnern also so als
ich dann doch nicht das vergessen habe
aber das war wasserwerk da saß nämlich
früher der bundestag und das war ein
bisschen so wie in zeiten des kalten
krieges als wirklich noch die position
aufeinander geprallt sind das darf man
auch erwarten dass muss man erwarten
dafür ist der deutsche bundestag da da
das der oppositionsführer und der
bundeskanzler dass die ihre position
darstellen können da liegen können und
werben können sie haben es da gelegt sie
haben geworben und sie haben sich
gegenseitig auch nicht wirklich geschont
am meisten im studio gelacht haben war
ja der beginn der scholz rede da sagte
er hätte sich von friedrich merz
motiv gewünscht
sich dieser kanzler moby hat sich mehr
fleisch gewünscht von herrn friedrich
merz muss nicht gleich ein friedrich
merz müsse sagen wo der schuh drückt und
wo der kanzler muss die leerstellen des
kanzlers offenlegen das hat er getan und
zwar keine waffen keine schweren waffen
keine kampfpanzer für die ukraine
zusammengestrichene listen merkwürdige
elend lange telefonate die scholz und
waggons zusammen mit wladimir putin
führen obwohl kaum noch jemand mit putin
telefoniert man auch nicht so richtig
weiß was das soll bei der nächsten tag
gut in die telefonate immer ins
gegenteil und nutzt die
propagandistische liegen den weg sagte
er das sei eine europa initiative
gewesen er sagt in europa europa
initiative erweckt den eindruck er sei
ein also er sein europäisch nie wenn
paris und berlin mit maske telefonieren
ist das nicht automatisch europäisch
dann ist es erst einmal westeuropäischer
sich die osteuropäer die das überhaupt
nicht lustig finden dass er permanent um
telefoniert wird und dass das land
propagandistisch ausgenutzt wird so aber
dafür ist der bundestag da muss nicht
jedes komma sitzen da muss nicht alles
stimmen was man sagt es darf nur nicht
komplett falsch sein und dafür sind
solche reden da und sagen wir dankbar
dass wir diesen deutschen bundestag kam
und also diesen freien austausch
deutschland und das land nicht gut das
war von friedrich merz gut und das war
jetzt von olaf scholz selbst für seine
verhältnisse außergewöhnlich gut
gekontert also ich hab sofort gesagt ich
hatte zwei kaffee der kanzler hatte
offensichtlich drei der waren stimmung
ja war auch angefressen und das muss man
auch merken und das ist gut dass man das
politikern auch anmerkt absolut vorbei
ein bisschen mehr hätte ich mir auch von
olaf scholz tatsächlich gewünscht muss
ich sagen von ihm selber und eben nicht
nur von friedrich merz weil auch viele
dieser fragen hat er eben dann doch
keine antwort geliefert also der
kasachen nicht beantworten und er muss
natürlich über 1 hinweg spielen also
wenn er
davon spricht dass es unanständig ist
dass die ukraine das man hier sagt was
die ukraine entscheiden mussten ukraine
da geht er darüber hinweg dass die
ukraine den krieg gewinnen will und wer
hier sagt die ukraine muss im krieg
gewinnen bevormundet ja die ukraine
nicht sondern die unterstützt sie diesen
satz sagt endlich und olaf scholz muss
rhetorisch natürlich verbrämen also
überdecken dass bei ihnen die pazifisten
in der fraktion ihm ins kanzler
steuerrad greifen und ganz vorne weg ist
rolf mützenich der fraktionschef das ist
ein überzeugter pazifist er redet auch
so und er denkt auch so und da gibt es
eine fraktion in der spd das problem
wohnt beim kanzler bei den leuten die
ihm aus der eigenen fraktion in
steuerrad reingreifen und ihm da würd
ich hart angehen nicht bei der
opposition die opposition heute das
gemacht wofür sie da ist lehrstellen
offen darlegen wirklich seltsam dass er
das die nicht über die lippen krieg wird
er wohl auch nie
für die einschätzung